hello everybody my name is Marc barn
welcome to let's play little Emily okay
this is a horror game that I know
nothing about once again I'm going into
this completely ignorantly so I'm a good
it may be good bad horrible it's from
gamejolt link is in the description
let's go okay well that's a good sound
however there seems to be a bit of a
problem my mouse is now drifting outside
of the box which is never a good sign
for a game but ok pick up five toy bears
and bring them to the Crypt if you say
so
so they've made on the Unity engine it
kind of reminds me - from slender right
away one with the collection mechanic
and - because this is pretty much the
stock forest that was Oh what was
stopped at ow my ears why why would you
do that to me ow that was just loud that
wasn't good
nothing happened okay alright then well
now that that has happened and I know
that's a thing I'm gonna look for some
toy bears and bring them back to the
Crypt I guess maybe I'm gonna crank my
volume down a lot cuz that almost
destroyed my eardrums this game is not
off to a good start in my book I'm in
for one I could have forgiven that maybe
it was like a slender clone with the
collection mechanics but don't throw ran
noises at me what is that I see
something over there
don't throw random noises for no reason
it's not scary just annoying okay teddy
bear
okay why was that a thing why did that
happen you want to tell me why you want
to reason your noises that you're making
I mean I like that ambiance noise I got
a ping on my mouth just all over the
place my mouse is just everywhere okay
so that toy bear I think I picked it up
I'm not sure okay that would have been
creepy if you just kept it up that was
really good but it stopped
haha okie dokie are you still there hi
what the hell are you supposed to be
what the hell hello hi lady you look
like Michael Jackson is this thriller
are we in a music video right now what's
going on here okay whatever I don't
think I actually picked up this bear so
I'm gonna try it again because it didn't
get the confirmation yeah okay alright
whatever
alright this game is more annoying than
scary I mean it could be good just a few
minor tweaks and it would be good take
out all the random ass noises that hello
does that mean that you're close behind
me or something or is that something
that I actually need to worry about
seems like I'm just in a giant box with
a bunch of things that I need a find
I've got two teddy bears so far I just
kind of need to scan around until I find
another one of those pillars I guess
this game is not very good I'll say that
right now but I always go into these
games with an intention to give it a try
oh is this that is that the Crypt is
that the crypt at which I need to bring
the teddy bears for some reason because
little emily is a little stupid stinky
head and trying to scare me okay there
was another crypt or a grave or a
cemetery thing in the bobber you know
what oh my god that almost startled me
no my god no my god okay giant head
floating randomly in a direction that I
was not looking very scary okay this
game definitely needed oh really
is this a thing let's do the frankenz on
Tuesday okay oh come on oh you're gone I
ran I ran out of rar juice oh man that
sucks this game it's getting more
comical as I go along which is pretty
good everyone loves a good laugh in a
horror game make you laugh lies Raghav
our robber robber robber robber robber
whatever whatever I'll just stand off to
the side here and make dick jokes or
whatever is it a cactus is that a cactus
in the middle of a garden or a forest or
whatever this thing is acapella go maybe
I haven't found anything else besides
more walls maybe one of these days I'll
find all five teddy bears but not
tonight I'll continue to dick around
until I die how about that
nah wait a minute I can't even look I
can't even clip into those trees ah we
were given a relatively high rating on
gamejolt but I'm guessing over there
they just encourage anyone that makes it
an indie game because which is good
attitude to have but some criticisms
need to stand I mean this is this it's
just a sad sad state of affairs over
here don't know what to say about this
in terms of improvement besides what
I've already said so I'll just continue
wandering around staring at my mouse
until something interesting happened
well what is that what is that I see a
light let's see a lamp hello hello is
somebody there huh
if somebody want to tell me what's going
on over here
is this the script that I've heard so
much about nah hmm
press e to open the door oh ha ha ha
what the hell
I haven't find five bears what what i
won
okay everybody congratulations through
that hard and arduous task that we were
tasked with now we managed to accomplish
at the skin of our teeth you know barely
made it in there as the ghost was
trampling our corpse oh I'm so happy we
made that so anyway if you want to try
this game out for yourself
click the link in the description if you
want to laugh at it just like I have
been click the link in the description
say your favorite part in the comment
below thanks for watching though thank
you all so much for watching click the
interface before videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
yeah
Wow
okay